one of the people that I think is is the
most interesting in in politics or media
right now which is Tulsi gabbard again
who is a you guys know this she was a
Democrat a progressive a lefty her
entire life she has now at least left
the Democrat Party she goes on Tucker a
lot she's hanging out with you know
crazy right-wingers like Dave Rubin and
she has been guest hosting for Tucker
and she had on just over the last couple
days uh there is a republican
Congressman newly elected Republican
Congressman George Santos and you may
have heard about this story it has now
turned out as he has been elected so he
won he is now a congressional freshman
uh it is turning out that his entire
resume is a lie not only the places that
he worked but he pretended that he had
family members who I think were
Holocaust Survivors then I think he said
he was gay but it turned out he was
married to a woman like it's so it's
like such a crazy ridiculous story
anyway Tulsi guest hosting for Tucker
had him on and did what Barbara Walters
did did she asked the tough questions
you don't really seem to be taking this
seriously you've apologized you said
you've made mistakes but you've outright
lie a lie is not an embellishment on a
resume you said you worked at Goldman
Sachs and Citigroup but they've said
we've got no record of this guy working
for us you've said you've gone to and
graduated from these universities but
they've said well we've got no record of
that these are blatant lies and it calls
into question how your constituents and
the American people can believe anything
that you may say when you are standing
on the floor of the House of
Representatives supposedly fighting for
them that's the real issue here
well look I and I I agree with what
you're saying and as I stated and I
continue
we can debate my my resume and how I
worked with firms such as is it
debatable or is it just false
debatable I no no it's not false at all
it's it's debatable I can I can sit down
and explain to you what you can do in
private equity in in capital intro via
servicing limited partners and general
partners and we can have this discussion
that's going to go way above the
American people's head but that's not
what I campaigned on I campaigned on
delivering results for the American
people by lowering inflation I can sit
down and if you want to have that
discussion I'd be glad to Tulsi to
explain that to you and make sure that
we we settled the score
that this is not about settling scores
and I think you just you just kind of
highlighted I think my concern the
concern that people at home have you're
saying that this discussion will go way
above the heads of the American people
basically insulting their intelligence I
actually don't even want to make this
about this Santos guy and it's to some
degree I don't even care that he lied
about his resume people lie about all
sorts of things now I would prefer that
they did not but the media now the rest
of the media which is not interviewing
him which is just talking about him is
saying he has to step down and how could
he lie and oh my God lying is so bad and
again I don't like lying but if only
they had ever asked questions about
another guy who lies a lot because
there's this guy who's always stumbling
and fumbling around do you know who I'm
talking about and he's always kind of
like wandering and saying crazy things
and pretty much lying about everything
uh I I I got raised in the black church
he knows I'm not kidding I got my
education
for real in the black church and that's
not hyperbole it's a fact I probably uh
went to school more than many of you did
you all think I'm kidding he can tell
you I'm
I was sort of raised in the Puerto Rican
community at home politically I just
have one thing to say
all right